and President Trump is vowing to push
forward on his promise to build a wall
on the southern border and restore order
in our immigration system joining us now
to debate these topics are gopac
chairman David Avella an immigration
attorney Francisco Hernandez all right
guys David I'll start with you I mean as
it relates to the wall the president
made it real clear that this is still on
the front burner for him he even made it
more clear that this week's cabinet
meeting judge when on Kirsten Nielsen
the new Homeland Security Secretary on
her new first day on the job someone in
that cabinet meeting told me he
repeatedly said to her build the wall
build the wall build the wall he is very
crystal clear on this and when you think
about that in the context of the
upcoming budget battle it is amazing to
think that the Democrats are gonna stop
funding for veterans homes for crisis
counseling centers and many other
important programs just so they can keep
illegal immigrants here all right and I
suspect Francisco that you might have a
different take but what was your tape
that will well he's talking like the
Democrats are in charge of Congress
Democrats are going to do this away with
this funding but look if President Trump
is right their illegal immigration is
down 70%
I guess problems solve we don't need the
wall let's get on the immigration reform
come on there's a lot of rhetoric but he
can't even get his Congress to authorize
one brick for the wall but you know what
when you say problem solved I mean you
can't help but a Francisco look at the
news and see some of the problems that
are happening that you know the opioid
epidemic it interests me more but
there's still 30 percent there's still a
zero David I'll let you take that in by
next year we'll be down to zero I guess
well let you make sure we are the this
this issue on the border and judge you
have been down there you know the
challenges we face with people being
able to bring harmful particular our
enemies bringing harmful things into our
country and this is really
that we're not going to just this is
just more than a personal security issue
for Americans this is an economic
security all you need is one of our
enemies to bring a bomb across this
border and blow up the Hoover Dam or
blow up an electrical grid and the
economic damage could be catastrophic
powers I'm sure they were here legally
and they stole a plane they didn't walk
across the border with a bomb come on
guys let's get real about it we're going
to legalize a hundred thousand Mexicans
to build a wall let's get going
all right Francisco you want to get real
what about what the president said when
he said Hispanic unemployment in this
nation is at an all-time low and I think
he said something like Hispanics weren't
going to they said they weren't going to
vote for me well they want the wall to
they want security was not at an
all-time low with President Obama did it
but that's you get it
citizen you know citizen Hispanics I'm
ok with that I agree with him there's
nothing wrong but it has nothing to do
with immigration Oh see okay do you want
to give him credit for that I did I did
but it has nothing to do with
immigration he can't even get in we we
can't even get illegal immigration right
now they want to reform legal
immigration I mean really guys
aggression because when you have a
lottery system and people come in and
kill us it's a problem David
ten seconds what you looking at yes yes
ma'am the president got elected in part
because of his pledge to secure the
border American he's expected and the
president is the deferment to deliver it
all right
thanks gentlemen